welcome to the stream we're gonna be
talking about this major piece of
legislation that Bernie Sanders has
proposed and which in the last couple
weeks but particularly the last 24 36
hours has picked up more than a dozen
total co-sponsors and I know
single-payer isn't going to pass well we
have a Republican in the White House
Republicans controlling the Senate and
Republicans controlling the house I get
that but this is still a major piece of
legislation number one because once we
finally have it scored and I'm going to
talk about what this thing will cost and
tax rates and the like but once we have
a new official scoring it will sort of
set a benchmark for what could be done
and it also really signifies the first
time that you've seen this level of
major Senate level support of a
medicare-for-all or single single-payer
bill so it is a very very interesting
bill and we're gonna be talking about it
in detail a couple things to test number
one I've gotten set up with stream labs
and there's a couple different things
that we are gonna be able to do during
the live streams with stream labs one is
you might be seeing at the bottom of the
window right now you can actually see
the chat that's on the side it's showing
up over the video and that's one thing
that is possible to do with stream labs
I don't know that that's necessarily
something that we want it is interesting
but I'm gonna turn that off for now but
what is enabled are two things number
one if you make a super chat now it will
actually pop up on the screen and it
will thank you and there will be an
animation and it will be really really
cool
so super chat is something that you can
use to send questions or comments and
when you send a super chat we're not
going to do it we'll have to wait for
the actual super chat apparently if it
works correctly an animation will
actually play and it'll thank you for
the super chat and it's all going to be
incredibly exciting the other thing is
someone apprised me last livestream that
if I get set up with stream labs people
can actually make
donations through stream labs and
YouTube will not take their cut from the
super chat and you can do that already
at stream Labs comm slash the david
pakman show and the link is in the
description for this video stream
labs.com slash the david pakman show and
those will also pop up on screen I think
I can test it let's see I think this is
what happens when there's a donation
let's see if it actually works here
there it is John donated $65 this is a
test donation for $65 I'm hoping that
it'll actually work when people do it
because this is just a test and then if
you do a super chat that will also pop
up on screen there it is david pakman
show donated 73 dollars through super
chat pretty exciting I'm liking this and
I don't yet know I don't know if it has
any kind of integration with patreon but
we are going to be looking into whether
that can be done and a lot of
interesting things should be possible
with this let's see what else can I do
in terms of I think that's mostly it
that that's that's what I've got going
on right now and we'll see we'll see if
this stuff works and I think that it'll
be exciting for all okay so let's talk
about the Bernie Sanders health care
bill okay I'm gonna go through it
basically in three parts how will it
work how will it affect the current
system that'll be a short discussion but
an important one and then how will it be
paid for which is obviously one of the
main questions whenever you have
so-called free stuff from a communist
like Bernie Sanders let's start with how
this will work okay
Medicare for all bill of 2017 the first
or second page maybe it is will have a
provision which says every individual
who is a resident of the United States
is entitled to benefits now
right-wingers are going crazy because
they are saying wait a second our
residents what if you're an undocumented
immigrant you are in a sort of
colloquial sense residing in the
United States so are you entitled to
Medicare for all if you're an
undocumented immigrant we don't know the
answer to that yet because as the
proposal from Bernie Sanders says the
Secretary will decide what the criteria
is for determining residency for
purposes of eligibility under this act
we just don't know the answer okay that
is going to be up to the secretary and
it is something that hopefully at some
point we will find out about I'm sure we
will but it is not something we have an
answer to right now okay number two how
will this work how do you enroll what
what is the function how does this all
happen the way it will work is that four
years after the bill is signed into law
four years after the bill is
hypothetically signed into law at some
undetermined point in the future it
would be phased in for every adult okay
and within a year of it being signed
into law it would be phased in for
individuals under 19 or to say at a
different way 18 or under and four years
is a very very long time to figure this
thing out plenty of time so no concerns
there whatsoever people who were born
after the enacting of the put of the
plan are automatically enrolled at birth
everybody gets a universal Medicare card
what would be covered most things okay
most of the things you would imagine
would be covered under this plan
hospital services that includes
inpatient outpatient emergency
prescriptions ambulatory patient
services primary and preventive care go
near regular doctor prescriptions and
medical devices would be covered mental
health and substance abuse treatment
would be covered labs and diagnostics
meeting blood tests MRIs cat-scans etc
reproductive maternity and newborn care
would be covered pediatrics would be
covered and oral health audiology and
vision services would be covered as well
as rehabilitation services okay now what
happens to states rights when this takes
place what would happen to states rights
if the Bernie Sanders Medicare for all
bill were to be enacted it's very
similar to Obama care where with Obama
care if it's a state already had
wanted to put in place something that
exceeded the requirements of Obamacare
they were free to do so and in the same
way the Bernie Sanders Medicare for all
2017 bill would allow states to put in
place systems single payer systems that
exceed the requirements of Medicare for
all how would they do that what would be
examples of exceeding the requirements
well we'll talk about that on the
program tomorrow there's something
there's actually put an interesting
conversation to be had there okay so
what happens to the current system we
have where we have mostly employer
connected health insurance paid for
usually in combination between the
employer and the employee although not
always if you're self-employed you're
paying for the entire thing to
for-profit insurance companies what
for-profit insurance companies will
still be allowed to exist they'll be
allowed to sell plans but for-profit
insurers under the Bernie Sanders
proposal would not be allowed to sell
plans that have the same benefits as
what Medicare will offer so clearly this
is a major blow to for-profit private
insurance there's no question about it
private insurers are totally free to
offer anything they want to above and
beyond what Medicare will cover but they
would not be allowed to say hey here's a
plan that covers the same stuff as
Medicare except it's a private
for-profit insurance plan would not be
allowed that will be controversial that
will absolutely be controversial
questions around the Commerce Clause
questions around other aspects of how
that will affect the insurance industry
and questions of people already talking
about Constitution and people talking
about freedom to transact business
there's a whole bunch of concerns there
okay and then what's the big matzo ball
hanging out there how is this going to
be paid for and of course the right is
very quick to say we can't afford it
somehow we can afford any war on a whim
but we can't afford health care for all
which just about every other developed
country can we can't afford it and it's
gonna be huge tax increases well listen
yeah it's going to be paid for by tax
increases the idea being though and
Canada is a good example of this the
idea being that the tax increases for
both employers and employees
over the long term will be less than the
savings from not having to pay for your
employees or your own health insurance
depending on whether you're an
individual or an employer so this it's
the math is complex in the sense that
we're talking about a major part of the
economy but the concept is simple which
is you eliminate so many levels of
bureaucracy and the entire insurance
involvement in medical billing you would
still have the government setting rates
for what providers would be paid for
trip for services and procedures you
would still have the providers billing
the government and that would come out
of the universal Medicare trust fund
which would which would be created and
we'll dig into that more in detail
tomorrow but you eliminate an entire
bureaucracy that currently exists and
it's very easy to understand when you
think about that how this would become
significantly less expensive okay and
then what about how much the tax will go
up right we actually don't have that
information yet and earlier this week
there was a Washington Post report which
says that according to Bernie Sanders
his own office the bill that we now have
is the proposal for how the program
would work and that a separate bill is
going to determine the cost now there
are opponents to this which by the way
include both right-wingers and there are
Hillary Clinton supporters all over my
facebook accounts saying that this is an
outrageous plan and that this is part of
what Hillary Clinton blamed Bernie for
offering free stuff with no way to pay
for it I would have rather seen how to
pay for it included in this bill but
there are legislative reasons why you
would separate those two things and it
has to do with appropriations there are
other reasons a separate bill will tell
us how much this is going to cost in
terms of tax increases that being said
there still is reason to believe that we
can have a pretty good assessment of
what this thing is going to cost Bernie
Sanders during the campaign had proposed
a medicare-for-all
bill and we could look at what that was
going to cost that was cost school
rather by the CBO and the CBO estimated
that Bernie's medicare-for-all proposal
from the campaign which is not identical
to what came out today but it's similar
in a lot of ways it would cost one point
four trillion dollars you would need to
put a 2.2 percent income tax on all
Americans and a 6.2 percent tax on
employers and there would be something
above and beyond on the very rich okay
so let's think for a second about not
the very rich let's look at the average
we actually just did a story on today's
bonus show if you don't have the bonus
show you should get the bonus show as
either a member or as a patron we did a
story on today's bonus show about how in
2016 we had a household median income of
about fifty nine thousand dollars okay
and that was actually one of the higher
household incomes median household
incomes of some time even though broadly
speaking we still do have significant
wage stagnation in the US so for the
average family income of fifty nine
thousand dollars the 2.2 percent tax is
one thousand two hundred and ninety
eight dollars per year per year
it doesn't take a lot to figure out why
that's a pretty good deal for most
families if you think of the average
family I think it's is it is the average
family size two point two or two let's
call it let's even call it three right
you've got a couple and one kid you are
very likely paying at least you're part
of your health insurance if you have it
sponsored through your employer is going
to be several hundred dollars per month
not per year added to the co-pays that
you're paying added to uncovered
benefits which include often a two
thousand dollar deductible on labs and
Diagnostics until that's covered etc one
thousand two hundred ninety eight
dollars for all of your health insurance
for the year and is quite a bit less
than what the average family is probably
paying now for the employer you're
talking about sixty
a six-point percent which works out to
about $3,600 again that is not nothing
but you would not have to be paying for
health insurance premiums based on
whether you have employees who are in a
family plan or single or whatever it
would really really simplify so I
actually think that that's quite
reasonable if that's what it ends up
being but no this is not going to pass
anytime soon that's just the reality
it's not gonna pass anytime soon and I
don't think anybody's gonna be surprised
by that but I look forward to the
scoring of this and I also look forward
to the reactions from the right will the
right attack Bernie's plan on the merits
or will they attack it ideologically
probably inaccurately but ideologically
as nanny state or communism or whatever
the case may be
we'll see we'll probably have some
examples of that by tomorrow now
this is actually making an impact this
is making an impact and and there are
pharmaceutical CEOs who are actually
worried about this I've got an article
let's see if I can pull it up here
bookmarked from the intercept by lee
fong who's been on the program several
times which says that brett some rent
saunders who's the chief executive of
allergen it's one of the bigger
pharmaceutical companies in the world he
is worried that americans are going to
be or are already so fed up with the
employer connected for-profit health
care system that we have that they are
going to really get behind maybe not
this proposal but a similar proposal
that might come out in the future who
knows and that it's going to be really
really bad for pharmaceutical companies
and when you have I've not read through
the entire article I will buy tomorrow's
program because I want to talk about it
when you have pharmacy EO saying this
isn't nothing I'm genuinely concerned
that we might see this garner
significant public support that's new
that's new and that is very very
interesting to me and
and I am curious as to what the next
several years are going to bring okay
let's do this sort of live stream
welcome this is a live stream if you've
never been on a live stream before it's
basically this we just hang out and chat
okay super chat is on and you can use
the super chat function to send your
questions and comments and we have
something now set up through stream labs
where when you send a super chat you
will actually see your name come up with
the super mario animation you can do
custom animations I like Mario Brothers
games so I picked this for today and
then that will come up everybody will
see it it'll be incredible and
absolutely tremendous and then I will
get to your question or comment you can
also you might have noticed look in the
description for this live stream and you
will see a link to Stream labs comm
slash the david pakman show you can send
the equivalent to a super chat through
stream labs stream labs.com slash the
david pakman show it will also come up
and it'll look like it will look like
this I guess there you go John donated
$49 and that's not for questions just
for donations but youtube doesn't take a
cut YouTube takes I never know exactly
what it is but they take a cut of Super
chats and you can skip that by going to
stream Labs comm slash the date the
david pakman show and while I was
talking I think there were a few
contributions was there I think Casey
more it's I'm still figuring out this
entire thing let's see if I look under
my donations Clark one two three four
sent the message no longer getting
cooked by Google $2 okay so I actually
see it and right now Clark one two three
four is the top donor because they are
the only donor producer Pat someone
claiming to use the name producer Pat
sent a three dollar and ninety nine cent
donation with the message only vegan
power of course now did that pop up I
can't even keep up with everything
that's going on can anyone tell me
whether the there it is
producer Pat donated 399 now I'm seeing
it on a delay okay all right well I
think people were just doxed
accidentally I apologize for any
accidental daxing okay so anyway there's
other graphics I could try and maybe
we'll try some of them later and we'll
see how the whole thing goes what I
would really love to do is be able to
put up the patreon contribution Target
or something like that I think that that
would be pretty cool but I don't I don't
really know how to do that we'll see
we'll see at some point I should be able
to do that oh and you know a well yeah I
don't want to I don't want to give
anything away but it appears that the
producer Pat donation may have actually
been clarf under a pseudonym pseudonym a
vegan power okay and then lastly just
number I'll go to number four please
don't troll trolling will get you banned
there our moderators moderate monitoring
the chat and number three new members
and patrons will get live thank-yous and
shout outs you can sign up at david
pakman.com slash membership patreon.com
slash david pakman show we're trying to
get to 2,000 patrons sooner than later
sooner than later would be good and we
did I'm not gonna bog down with
everything the entire story but we had a
sort of not a Mia culpa because I wasn't
taking blame for anything but I did a
sort of heart-to-heart on today's
broadcast show explaining to people sort
of where things are with YouTube D
monetization and if you've been
following YouTube news at all lately and
you're aware of what's going on with
PewDiePie and the N word debacle and
even cooking videos and other stuff
being demonetized if cooking videos are
being demonetized on youtube we're
screwed right I mean there is there is
absolutely no way around that because
what we're doing while I believe is
still not controversial it should
absolutely be considered more serious I
guess you would say then cooking shows
although cooking is important cooking
very very important
thanks to Jakob all their love the
animation we just donated donated ten
dollars through super chat so anyway
I'll start answering questions here but
please make those contributions patreon
membership thank you sir happening it's
it's all crazy it's all crazy
just as a reminder I do have this other
tool in my quiver which is that I can
put on the chat in the main window
but maybe it's distracting like I don't
know what we're gaining you know you can
just see it on the side I don't know do
people like the chat overlay I don't I
don't know that I'm loving it I'm gonna
turn it off for now but we'll keep the
donation alerts and the patreon the
sorry the super chat alerts what would
be cool and I will get into the question
soon would be if there was a way to put
the super chats actually up on the
screen I think there is a way to do that
with stream labs but I don't yet know
how we'll see we'll see if somebody
knows how to do that please tell me okay
and then I will I will get that done
okay no chat overlay people don't like
it let's start with some of these super
chats people do have questions the d2j
bug is sent to five Canadian dollar
super chat I'm having a hard time
smurfing the way you Smurf okay thank
you I appreciate that
christina has sent a $2.00 super chat
what is your favorite color
cerulean cristian cerulean is my
favorite color
Jacob ball I'm kidding by the way Jacob
ball sent the $10 super chat would it
make sense for Democrats to call the tax
increase a premium it would be easier to
make the case that you're reducing
premiums then to state that you're
raising taxes PS love the graphic Jacob
I think that you know on the program
today I mentioned that a lot of how
weather and to what extent this plan is
attacked by Republicans will depend on a
few things number one how much of a
threat they see it as and even though
it's a good thing you'd say why would
you call something that's good a threat
doesn't really make sense
depending on how much of a threat
Republicans see Bernie's proposal to be
they might attack it more or less the
messaging that Democrats use is
absolutely going to be a factor and I
think it is a very interesting
yeah and it had not occurred to me to
say this isn't the biggest tax increase
in the history of the US or whatever
which I mean how we do it is what it is
we can call it a number of different
things instead of calling it a tax
increase we call it the biggest
reduction in health care premiums and
and the underlying costs as a result of
eliminating so many bureaucratic
expenses in the history of modern health
care and I think that that is a very
very interesting Jacob and in fact I'm
gonna make a note of it in my notes for
tomorrow let me see if I can do that
here and I will quote quote you Jacob
ball idea of biggest decrease in
premiums rather than huge tax increase
yeah that's very interesting and I think
the messaging is a major major component
so I am looking forward to checking to
thinking about that and to seeing what
the messaging is around a lot of this
these bills
Bernie's bootlegs and more has sent a $2
super chat would you have a full debate
with Ben Shapiro on your show I don't
know what you mean by full debate but
I've said before I'm glad to talk about
a particular topic with Ben Shapiro and
I would be interested in having him on I
don't know that he wants to be on you
know he's got quite a quite a busy
schedule it seems like and I I'm glad to
have him on we I email with him every
once in a while we will shoot an email
back and forth about something that's
something I saw something he saw of mine
or whatever I'm willing to have him on
and I think it would be interesting I
want to thank someone who is donating at
stream labs.com slash the david pakman
show under the name david's underscore
girlfriend the amount of $2 with the
message the chat overlay is good if
people don't watch live that's an
interesting idea
that's an interesting idea can we are
you know I don't know whether can
someone tell me when the donations go
through at stream labs calm
/ the david pakman show dude does the
message also show up I'm just not sure
whether it does I don't know whether it
does and that is a little difficult for
me to really test or see I hope it does
because one of the main things about
super chat is the message it does okay
people are saying it does very very good
so anyway if you've just joined we have
now set up stream labs.com slash the
david pakman show so if you if you make
a contribution at stream labs.com slash
the david pakman show instead of through
super chat you can still send me a
message and it'll come up on screen and
we skip the 30% cut that YouTube takes
from super Chat revenue so that's an
interesting idea but by all means feel
free to use super Chat super Chat is
happening and many many other things are
of course happening ok I want to do some
thank-yous let me do this I've not done
this and I'm being as I'm trying to be
good I know people don't like it when we
do too much of this but I do want to do
some membership thank-yous because there
there have been fortunately several
coming in when you become a member at
david pakman.com slash membership i
thank you during the livestream and that
is very exciting to some people and sad
to others
Oh real quick the d2j bug has donated
through super chat and I want it wanted
to make sure that that got on you go to
david pakman.com slash membership you
sign up if you want a discount you can
put that discount code up on the second
page of the signup process and that
coupon code is I voted 17 some of the
people who have signed up during the
live stream so far Henry O'Brien thank
you for signing up Henry very much
appreciate it Robert Stadnyk has become
a member
Jennifer Kinsley or Kinzel has become a
member janda Reuter has become a member
Rob Rome or Roy me has become a member
are Newell form are of nori pho Vargas
has become a member
Lori Kahn has become a member and Stuart
Reeves has upgraded his subscription
which I very very much appreciate
on the patreon site patreon is a big
deal we're trying to get to 2,000
subscribers when we get to 3,000 we are
launching patreon only content patreon
donations of $5 now unlock access to the
world's famous bonus show patreon
contributions of $10 now unlock not only
the bonus show and the behind-the-scenes
videos and the Members Only newsletter
but also the full daily broadcast show
and a few patrons that I want to thank
Brian last has just made a pledge of $1
Shaun Mahoney has just increased his
pledge from 10 to 12 dollars a month
Rodney Stephen Pratt has made a $2 a
month pledge and waring has made a $2 a
month pledge and Michael Kern's has
multiplied his pledge tenfold from 1 to
10 dollars per month and thanks to
everybody thanks to everybody who did
that really really appreciate that and
also thanks to people who are helping us
test out this new paradigm of
contributions at stream labs.com slash
the david pakman show stream labs.com
slash the david pakman show and another
contribution under the name producer Pat
of $2 if you don't sign up David won't
buy me vegetables yeah of course
producer Pat is vegan and when he
doesn't get vegetables he gets very very
upset he gets very very upset and he
doesn't want to be relying on Soylent as
he has talked to us about so yes please
make contributions so that Pat can get
some vegetables and thanks to Jimmy
Smith who has made a $2 contribution I
appreciate that as well thanks very much
ok one quick other super chat and then I
want to get into a couple of other
things here
the d2j bug has said needs more guiles
theme you know there is there's this
really funny thing I'm just gonna test
this I don't know if we can do it
there's an as you probably noticed when
people do super chat
or donations now you hear a little audio
chime so to speak there is an option for
that that sounds to me a lot like Donald
Trump sorry I think I might have
accidentally tested a super shot before
changing it tell me if you like this I
think that this is a little weird but it
might be interesting to people it's it's
it's a voice that sounds to me like
Donald Trump and it's almost kind of
sexual I don't know let me just save it
and then we'll try it together
it's if you like this I'll keep it okay
so this could be the testing super chat
does that sound like Trump to anybody
else I don't know it seems to sound like
Trump to me yeah okay let me get into
some other things we're clear
everybody's clearly very very excited
about these new things that are going on
so James d'amour is gonna be joining me
on the program next week
James d'amour is the guy who has become
quite well-known because he was fired by
Google fired by Google after he
criticized the diversity policy of
Google and he's done a bunch of
interviews he was on the Joe Rogan
program he was on Dave Reubens program
and he tweeted to me saying I'm a fan of
your show and I would like to be on your
program and that was interesting to me
so we are going to be doing a two-part
interview with James d'amour if you have
questions for questions for James James
d'amour please write in through our
website or you can tweet me or submit
your questions via super chat or at
stream labs.com slash the david pakman
show whatever I am NOT going to be doing
an interview that is going to be super
similar to what you might have seen on
the dave rubin program or on the Joe
Rogan program I am gonna be really
trying to figure out where it is that he
has developed a lot of these ideas and I
think it's going to be an interesting
interview let's put it that way and he
has imposed absolutely no restrictions
whatsoever so far on what we can talk
about and what
and asked and I'm looking forward to
talking to him and also I'm really
looking forward to interviewing
Elizabeth Kolbert Elizabeth Kolbert
wrote this book the sixth extinction
which was highly recommended by former
President Barack Obama a guy that lots
of us remember at this point and I am
really looking forward to talking to her
the idea is generally speaking that
there have been five major extinctions
on the planet and that we are arguably
debatably in the middle of the sixth
major extinction right now and of course
even extinctions that happen quickly
based on the lifetime the life the
longevity of the average human and even
how long we've had sort of modern
record-keeping it can be hard to tell
that we are in this extinction so we're
gonna be speaking with Elizabeth Kolbert
her book is absolutely brilliant I read
it not long ago and she's going to be on
the program and we've got a lot of
really really great stuff coming up so I
think that it's it's gonna be a good
couple of weeks on the program and then
it's been you might have noticed that
during the August vacation we put out a
bunch of long-form videos and then there
haven't been any new ones on YouTube for
a while even though we have been using
them on the broadcast program we have
been working on a really really
complicated long-form video about race
and IQ and we're going to be coming at
this from all angles we are going to
address that recent episode about the
bell curve on Sam Harris's podcast which
has caused a lot of contributions but we
are also going to be digging into many
many other aspects of that and that is
upcoming I can't tell you exactly when
yet but it's going to be really really
good okay Jacob ball has sent a $2 super
chat you're making super chats great
again David thank you
I'm doing my best also a couple of new
or one new contribution at stream
labs.com
slash the David Pakman show
from Christina who has made a dollar
contribution saying I want to make the
Mario move right
yeah people now hey if you're just
contributing to get the animation to
play that's fine I've got a long list of
animations it's gonna be a while before
we get through all of the animations and
I have not no no other new animations
for you so by all means keep it going
okay so what else will we be talking
about on tomorrow's program we're good
obviously gonna do a full full breakdown
of Bernie Sanders healthcare Medicare
for all 2017
bill I'm going to be talking about this
pharmacy EO and I mentioned this earlier
today tonight in the stream the pharmacy
EO who is worried that there is going to
be significant energy behind Bernie's
proposal or a similar one
I also that this has slipped by and
without much attention in a lot of media
outlets because so much else is going on
but during a recent press briefing I
think it was uh it was yesterday or
maybe the day before White House press
secretary Sarah Huckabee Sanders said
that the Justice Department should look
at prosecuting fired former FBI director
James Comey and I believe although I
bookmarked it I haven't read it in
detail yet I believe she even might have
said that the White House is looking at
what personnel specific charges they
might recommend the Justice Department
explore which of course is not at all
the role of the White House full-stop
right I mean just you don't have to add
anything so we're gonna be talking about
that and I'm also going to be doing an
update about that vendor that immigrant
vendor from UC Berkeley who had who is
not only ticketed for selling hotdogs
from a little cart without a license but
he also had his money seized over
seventy thousand dollars have now been
raised and it is a very interesting
story and I've been in contact actually
via Facebook with Martin Flores who is
the guy that filmed that incident that
we told you about on Monday and it is a
very interesting story that I am looking
forward to updating
tomorrow and if we have time it's it's
I'm I really want to do a thorough job
with the Bernie healthcare bill so I
don't know how much we'll have time for
tomorrow because we've already got a
bunch of stories that I mentioned but
Brian Kilmeade of Fox & Friends and Fox
News Radio Fame says that Americans are
no longer pure because we marrying other
species I thought it was just Homo
sapiens
marrying Homo sapiens but apparently he
I guess he was maybe talking about race
or now who knows what he was talking
about it's ludicrous no matter what he
was saying but he said Americans aren't
pure because Americans keep marrying
other species and we will find out maybe
what species he's talking about I don't
know very very strange incredibly
strange stuff super chat $10 super Chet
from 280z Turbo single-payer isn't free
but neither is your current health care
employers don't give out health care
from the goodness of their hearts
Democrats should talk more about cost
savings less about morality yeah you
know I'm actually if I'm a 280z turbo
you're making a very interesting point
that I also would like to address
tomorrow which is you don't need to make
a morality argument 280z turbo you don't
need to make a morality argument for
democrats democrats are already going to
support a bill like what we saw proposed
by Bernie Sanders on the merits they
basically get it right so it does make
sense to think about how you should
explain this to the right or to the
middle or to the other side or
libertarians or whoever and I think that
talking about as Jacob ball said earlier
which I'll address tomorrow on the show
frame this as one of the biggest
reductions to health care premiums even
accounting for what you will be paying
in taxes in the history of modern
for-profit insurance connected a
for-profit employer connected health
insurance so yeah I think that that's
absolutely a great idea Dylan collet has
sent a $2.00 super Chad what's your
favorite drumming rudiment and why yeah
so you might have noticed in other
people have that I have over here
this is a I think it's a 4 inch snare
drum and because I live in an apartment
and I've got neighbors there and there
and over there I can't really play a
loud drum so I actually have a series of
three practice pads on top of it to
deaden the sound and with those I can
still have the snares on and it's not
super loud I would say my favorite
rudiments are I like the double
paradiddle because you can interpret it
both in 4/4 time and in twelve eight or
six eight or some other time signature
even in three four actually
interestingly enough and you can sort of
overlay it in different ways on
different time signatures so I like the
double paradiddle and I'm also a fan of
the not the flam tap but the it's the
flam - three flam - three I forget what
it's called not the flam tap but the
flim it's like a flam triplet I forget
what that one's called but yeah that's
that's another good one that I like for
warmups anyway so boring - non drummers
but yeah Jacob ball has sent a $2.00
super chat if super chats were a species
I'd marry them alright Jacob all very
very excited I I have a you know we're
getting a sort of normal number of super
chats but it seems like people are
really liking the animation that plays
now what I'm not understanding is
there's supposed to be a sound that
plays when there's a super chat
animation can people tell me in the chat
whether they're hearing the sound
because I'm not I'm not sure if you are
I'll put the chat overlay on just for a
moment are people hearing the sound when
there are donations double paradiddle
sounds sexual there's no sound says
Joseph Zynga talk more about Bernie no
sound not hearing any sound that is
interesting you know that is actually a
surprise to me because there is a sound
that is
that's configured I wonder why people
aren't hearing it I'm hearing it is the
sound maybe not coming through I don't
know I don't see anything that indicates
why you would not have sound on that
okay wasn't here if anybody is familiar
with with stream labs which we're now
using please contact me after the stream
with two tips one why might people not
be hearing the sound associated with the
donation and super chat animations if
someone says they did get sound a bunch
of people are saying they're hearing the
sound didn't hear the sound sample
earlier Wow okay if someone can help me
sort that out please do also if someone
can tell me how I can put the donations
and super chat messages overlaid that
would also be really appreciated because
I like to do those two things I think
it'll increase audience engagement and
on that note cloth one two three four
did send the donation that I want to get
to a $2.00 donation through stream Labs
comm slash the david pakman show who
lost more money from google recently
James d'amour or David Pakman that's a
good question
that's a good question I mean you know
this is pretty bad I don't know how much
James d'amour was being paid by Google
so I couldn't tell you who lost more
what with what's going on with the
monetization but I can tell you we lost
enough that the New York Times found it
worthwhile to write about and a really
great article by Amanda Hess that's
available on our web site on the press
page also a really great article in
Wired that is available by Davey Alba on
our website and very very well written
articles okay let me get caught up on
thank-yous and then I will not do any
more until the end of the stream of
course you can sign up for membership
david pakman.com slash membership coupon
code saves you 40%
I voted 17 is the coupon code members
get the commercial-free all-access pass
they get the bonus show they get invites
the members only live streams they get
the behind-the-scenes videos they get
members-only monthly update a lot of
very exciting stuff going on for members
i want to send a big thank you to jordan
force jordan force has just that's a
good name
jordan force is kind of like max power
and i'm sure if anybody remembers that
simpsons episode but jordan force is a
very strong name
thanks to jordan for signing up i want
to welcome back to membership
christopher or actually i don't know if
this is a new member it's a very similar
name to someone that used to be a member
anyway christopher Tandberg thank you
for signing up at david pakman.com slash
membership Craig chambers I also want to
thank for signing up at david pakman.com
slash membership and sadly patreon is a
little sad tonight i've only had a
handful of contributions through patreon
and no new ones to mention right now so
that that's sad that is really really
sad so please continue to make those
contributions at patreon.com slash david
pakman show thanks to Jamal Swift who
made a $10 contribution through super
chat oh you know what I don't know if
I'm supposed to be saying people's names
because now I'm realizing that I should
be saying to ATZ turbo
no I'm not Jamal Swift actually did make
a contribution ok I see things are just
on a delay here Jamal Swift $10 what is
your opinion on Colin Kaepernick ok I
don't do a lot of sports commentary
mostly not because I don't care about
sports but because the audience seems to
really not like it when I do sports
commentary i number-one believe there is
nothing problematic about Colin
Kaepernick protesting by not standing
during the national anthem and it is
unintelligible to me how there can be
people who say they simultaneously
criticize political correctness because
they believe it is sort of a forced
normative infrastructure why let the
science same time saying everybody needs
to stand
when the national anthem is sung the
same type of thing it's not political
correctness they call it patriotism they
call it respect for country whatever but
it's the same type of forced normative
standards so if you are worried about
the PC police and you think Colin
Kaepernick shouldn't be sitting or
kneeling during the national anthem
you've got to figure out your priorities
okay as so politically I have no problem
with what he's doing whatsoever beyond
that you know I think he's a fine
quarterback I think he showed last week
that he's certainly a better quarterback
than some starting quarterbacks in the
NFL
although beyond that I couldn't really
say much I'm not
I really mostly just follow the Patriots
all right Christina making $1
contribution it's stream' labs.com
slash david pakman show how often do you
open your window shades or do you
usually leave them closed yeah these are
basically always closed because you
don't want to know what's on the other
side of those window shades maybe if we
ever get to five thousand patreon
contributors I will show you what's
beyond those windows shades but it is
grim when you put it that way it is very
very grim and I've got very serious and
specific reasons why those window shades
are not opened it would be would be a
scary thing it would be a very very
scary thing okay let me do something
I've not had time to do between the
super chats and the donations and the
contributions and all the different
stuff which is take a look through the
regular chat for questions and answer
some of those where is pat pat has his
own place where for the time being we're
maintaining separate apartments so pat
pat has his own place David do you teach
so you can put more money into the show
by taking a smaller paycheck from its
budget no that's not why I teach I teach
because I've always been interested
teaching and it's very it's a totally
different experience and I'm really
enjoying it what is super male vitality
somebody asks that is a supplement sold
by Alex Jones okay people talking about
the sound people talking about Mario
people telling me that I don't have the
sound connected correctly
why has socialism failed in Vietnam
check out our long-form piece about
socialism let's see what else we've got
here technically both James d'amore and
David Pakman have been fired by Google
in a sense in a sense somebody alleging
clickbait that I'd be talking about the
health care bill based on the title we
did we talked about it for a half hour
we'll talk about it again tomorrow now
I'm answering audience questions you can
at any time rewind and go back to the
beginning of the live stream David what
are your thoughts on PewDiePie saying
the n-word I believe that it has only
made the D monetization problem worse so
if you thought that this was bad the
David Pakman show
losing 85 to 88 percent of our revenue
the fact that such a prominent youtuber
has now made headlines because he used
the n-word seemingly pretty damn
casually during a stream of him playing
a video game it's not going to be good
for anybody who's on YouTube which is
we've basically written off YouTube as a
revenue source at this point and we are
trying to make up the money else how I
guess I would say in other ways okay
let's see what other questions we've got
here in the regular chat always want to
go through and see what people are
talking about is it just me or is the
video going total potato now yeah I
don't know what happened but most people
seem to think the video was okay how big
will how much push back world would be
from the insurance companies to Bernie's
proposal it's going to depend on how
much of a risk they think it is that it
might actually pass right that's really
what it's going to come down to okay
people talking about is there sound is
there no sound have I talked to Louis
about twitch streaming
I have not I have not broached that
subject with Lois at this point okay and
I think those are most of the questions
there yeah I'm not seeing everybody
anybody else will there when will an
alternative to YouTube be available you
know the thing is there's plenty of
alternatives to YouTube already the
problem is they don't have the audience
YouTube has so even with the
monetization what we're trying to do and
it's possible YouTube will crack down on
this is to you use the the audience and
platform that we have on YouTube to talk
about the YouTube funding issue that
we're having and thus try to generate
contributions and revenue sources
elsewhere I mean that's the that's the
general idea and it's not it's certainly
no panacea and I think that's evident
from the fact that we've had to continue
we've had to continue fundraising and
that's that's just what's going on it's
the reality okay let me what I had a
couple other things I wanted to do oh so
people mentioning the hair thing yet
when we get to 2,000 patrons at
patreon.com slash david pakman show this
is the infamous picture and I posted
this to my Instagram account a couple
months ago I said when we get to 2,000
patrons at patreon.com slash david
pakman show I will do an entire stream
I'm sorry an entire broadcast show at
the David Pakman show studios with my
hair like this and it'll be quite a show
that I can assure you and we are close
we are over 1900 and so that's the hair
thing that people were asking about what
else were people asking about that I
wanted to comment on other long-form
pieces that we have in the works yeah
let me talk to you about that so I
mentioned earlier in the stream that we
are very actively working on a long-form
piece on where is my list I'm not
finding my list of one for oh here it is
long-form video ideas so we're work
on race and IQ right the connection
between race and IQ the controversy over
race in IQ etc etc that we're working on
I want to do a cryptocurrency explainer
cryptocurrency is becoming a pretty
major thing and I've been experimenting
with it on a very small level on a
laughably small level I would say and a
lot of people don't understand
cryptocurrency and the three big big
ones are Bitcoin aetherium and litecoin
so I think doing a long form piece on
not only how cryptocurrency works but
also the impact it could have on major
currencies like the dollar if it were to
grow significantly and how these
alternative currency markets work I
think that would be really really
interesting we still have this critical
thinking miniseries that I am trying to
finalize and hopefully soon we will have
in sort of production I guess I would
call it although it's some of the
production has already been done I want
to do here's an idea I haven't even
mentioned this but since we're chatting
among friends I will mention it I
thought it would be interesting you know
how people often make comparisons to
Nazis and Hitler and very often we have
to explain and we have to say no that's
not really like the Nazis are Hitler
sort of a Godwin's law video where we
could say when can we start saying this
that or the other thing are like the
Nazis or Hitler in other words what
principles could we look at that are a
little more broad than just oh well
you're killing Jews to say this actually
is becoming not sziasztok I think that
would be interesting and along those
lines I had this other idea I made a
note of how white nationalism becomes
normalized and how it has become
normalized right and we've seen that
happen thanks Jacob for the $2 super
chat I appreciate that we'll get to the
message in a bit we've seen it sort of
happen with Trump actually which is
first these sort of thinly veiled
appeals that serve as coded language to
white supremacists and white
nationalists and then the idea of I of
some a white identity as being just
another type of identity and why would
be against that and sort of the process
that we
scene of the normalization of white
supremacy and white nationalism I think
particularly in light of the Bernie
Sanders proposal today we're gonna do an
analysis of the bill in detail tomorrow
but I think a long-form piece that would
look more into why we don't have
national health care to begin with
there's a really interesting story that
wendell potter former Cigna executive
tells in his book deadly spin I've
interviewed him about it you can check
it out on our YouTube channel in the
archives there's a long story to be told
about why we don't have national health
care nationalized health care and about
what that would look like and how it
would cost thank you for the
contribution to Cold War 45 who just
donated 20 bucks through super chat
we'll get to your message shortly now so
that's another long-form piece that I'm
looking at and also this was suggested
last on the last stream the war on drugs
really looking at the origins of the war
on drugs in some pretty extensive detail
and we all have sort of an intuitive
sense about a lot of elements of that of
the war on drugs and the racist
components and how it connects to Civil
Rights Act of 1964 I think there's a lot
there and we've not really covered that
in detail so I think that's an
interesting idea as well thanks to Tom
Torino who has donated ten dollars
through super chat asking about Martin
shkreli going to jail I will get to that
momentarily okay let's let's jump into
the super chat questions because they
are coming up here Jacob ball has sent
the $2 super chat hashtag dogecoin 20 20
is it Doge are Doge I never know because
I only see it written yeah I guess
that's another cryptocurrency not one I
am dabbling in I can tell you with with
absolute and total certainty we will
next go to a $5 per chat from Justin
Sanchez any ghost has sent the $20 super
chat and I appreciate that we will get
to any ghosts question shortly Justin
says I think you should telethon it up
it was great it was exciting to meet
patreon goals during the livestream
naysayers gonna naysay and probably not
consume
contribute either way okay listen let's
just do this real quick we've got very
very little time left in the stream but
the contributions have been coming in
via patreon we started the evening I
think it 1902 patrons let's see where we
are right now
I'll set like a mini goal just for you
Justin we are at 1908 patrons met right
now if we get to 1915 by the end of the
stream that's just seven more patrons I
will knock out for you a 55% membership
discount code and then announce it on
the stream okay just seven patrons at
patreon.com slash david pakman show and
one more might have just rolled in so
we're this is a it's a mini it's an
insta telethon just for you Justin cold
war 45 cent a $20 super check talk to
Ben from drunken peasants he can help
with stream labs that use stream labs on
their show all the time and they have
the voice and it works fine okay Ben
from drunken peasants I don't have a
direct contact to bend from drunken
peasants
when I was on producer pat vegan
producer Pat actually lined up that
interview okay I'm Tirreno $10 super
chat did you hear the news about Martin
shkreli going to jail for putting a
bounty on a lock of Hillary Clinton's
hair I did hear about it and you know I
did not
shkreli Clinton hair jail I did not
bookmark the article for tomorrow's
program but I'm pulling up the New York
Times article on it the particulars by
the way that the New York Times using of
Martin shkreli he looks a lot like a JD
har Meyer from the Howard Stern Show in
this particular picture I will check
into that okay let me do a couple more
of these super chats but I should also
just double check who's contributed at
stream labs.com slash the david pakman
show this is new if you contribute at
stream labs.com slash the david pakman
show you will forego the cut of your
super chat that YouTube takes okay
Christina sent another dollar super
check Christina I kind of like the
questions from Christina they're very de
mess
dick and mundane but they're they're
very specific also and it's great to
have specific questions Cristina said do
you have a washer and dryer or do you
need to go to a laundromat no I have a
washer and dryer and I'm able to do all
forms of laundry including linens towels
and bath mats right here in my apartment
it's a wonderful thing
Clarke 1 2 3 4 also sent a $2.00 stream
lab contribution saying David don't
listen to that telethon cuck it's too
late
I made the telethon challenge of 1915
patrons at patreon.com slash David
Pakman show and if we meet that goal by
the end of the stream I will launch for
you a 55% membership discount code I did
I'm sorry Clark I didn't know that you
were opposed to it any ghost has sent a
$20 super chat David I've become
obsessed with the idea of
cross-pollination between political
youtubers I'd love to see you on say
steven crowder show because if you bust
the echo chambers you'd eat him alive
and convert some folks I would be glad
to be on with steven crowder as long as
we had you know an agreed-upon
topic I don't want to be sandbagged but
yeah I've been talking at the Boston
College class that I'm teaching about
filter bubbles and echo chambers etc and
I think that that that's a really
interesting idea I'd be glad to be on
with Steven I don't know that he wants
me on I don't know that he wants me on
dumbass loser has sent a $2 super chat
what percentage of books do you read
fiction versus nonfiction it's pretty
close to 5050
maybe I'm getting through you know I
think it's pretty much 50/50 I usually
have one or two fiction books that I'm
reading simultaneously I read fiction at
night I found that I always had an
instinct that reading nonfiction at
night was the opposite of relaxing like
I'll start falling asleep on reading
fiction at night but reading nonfiction
is not good at night and Tim Ferriss
said I'm not like a big Tim Ferriss guy
but I caught one video he did he says
that reading nonfiction engages the
problem-solving sort of function
of the mind and that that's why reading
nonfiction at night isn't the best thing
kind of an interesting thing but I think
it's about 50/50 right now I'm reading
two non-fiction books one is called I
think it's called anxiety of affluence
by Rachel Sherman she's gonna be on the
program so I'm trying to finish it
pretty quickly
uneasy Street the anxieties of affluence
and then the other one is a book that
Bill Gates recommended by Nick Lane the
book is called the vital question the
vital question by Nick Lane very
interesting very very interesting book
and as far as fiction I'm reading and
reading a whole bunch of fiction stuff
right now actually I've got a lot I
actually don't remember the name of the
book I'm reading so I will forego
telling you any ghosts sent the $2 super
chat telling me the G in dogecoin is
soft David alright Singh has sent the $5
super chat I appreciate that Sean
Maguire sent the $5 super chat wish me
luck
on Saturdays LSAT taking the LSAT the
entrance exam for most law schools
although I don't know that every law
school is still doing the LSAT thing but
I think for the most part most of them
are good luck Sean very very I hope you
do well and I think it's an interesting
test the interesting test a lot of logic
in it dannevig has sent a $5 super chat
what are your thoughts on the Catalonian
independence referendum coming up in 18
days seems to be very possible according
to the polls yeah you know my my dad's
wife is from Spain but from a different
region of Spain not from Catalonia and I
have not really been following it I've
been sort of I've been aware of the
Catalonian independence movement as a
movement in Spain for a very long time
but I've not been following the polling
so I wouldn't be able to say much about
it although I do find it very very
interesting alright let's do some thank
yous I don't know if we're gonna make it
to our target of 1915 patreon
contributors we are six away at one
in 909 Ryan Henderson has made a
dollar-a-month pledge and Garth Poulos
has made a $2 a month pledge and the
great Derrick Busby has made a $10 a
month pledge at patreon.com slash david
pakman show i've got a few minutes left
to hang and then we're gonna have to
wrap up the stream but i will tell you
that we are six patrons away from
getting to nineteen fifteen and if we do
that I will create just for you I won't
announce it anywhere I will create a
fifty five percent discount code for
membership and then you'll be able to
sign up for membership at a fifty five
percent discount that's more or less how
it will work so if that's interesting to
you please get those contributions in
because the live stream is starting to
wrap up Kim Williams thank you for
sending a five-dollar super check do you
ever look into the effect of the opioid
crisis panic on health challenges people
on health challenges people that use
opioid to have the ability to lead a
semi-normal life the effect of the
opioid crisis panic on health challenges
people I'm having trouble parsing the
question but I've studied the opioid
crisis to some degree I'm by no means
any kind of an expert on it by no means
at all and I don't know that I'm
equipped to answer your question Kim
specifically but I will
maybe I'll just google what you said and
see what comes up I'm just not a hundred
percent sure exactly what the what the
question is okay so to sum up we now
have a new system for contributions and
questions during the live stream stream
labs.com slash the David Pakman show
when you make a stream labs contribution
or you make a super chat contribution we
get an animation that comes up on the
screen it thanks you it's cool people
seem to like it so that's an exciting
new thing that we've been able to do we
are continuing to stand by to see if we
get to 1915 patrons
we are still six away six dollar
contributions will do it but we have
only a little bit of time left in the
stream
Joseph Zynga has sent a five-dollar
super chat no question or comment I'll
go through some of the comments and
questions in the super chat are you on
the radio says the mass gamer yes the
David Pakman show is on around a hundred
radio stations around the country
I want the bagel with the cream cheese I
don't know if that is a donation that's
available on stream labs but I'd be glad
to look into that somebody asking do I
think the stronger support from Medicare
for all of for all from the Democrats
will improve their chances in the 2018
election great question I have been
suggesting to Democrats not that they
care what I say for months now that they
take a principled and not compromising
position on Medicare for all or
single-payer start with that doesn't
mean it's going to happen in fact it's
not going to happen when Trump is
president and Republicans control the
House and Senate it's just not but take
a principled position and start the
negotiation from there right don't start
from a weaker point start from a strong
point and something that we can really
get behind and I think that that would
be that that would be it's a start and
they're gonna need to go beyond just
Medicare to really build a platform for
2018 that is independent of we're not
Trump Singh has sent a $2 super check
your thoughts on 9/11 is the government
hiding anything yeah most governments
hide certain aspects of major disasters
of this kind that is very very separate
from did Bush Planet was it an inside
job did somebody paint the World Trade
Center with thermite paint to make it go
you know collapse more quickly just
because there are probably elements that
have been discovered that are being sort
of hidden or held back that doesn't
that's not evidence of a broader
conspiracy the way some conspiracy
theorists have suggested I think that
that that's sort of the general idea
okay that is gonna do it for the
livestream thanks to everybody who
joined me thanks to everybody who
contributed through the new platforms
please let's keep it going let's
continue building the David Pakman show
more on the program tomorrow